migrant lawlessness is getting worse in
Liberal cities a gang of moped riding
illegal immigrants have been terrorizing
New Yorkers by snatching cell phones
right out of their hands one horrific
video showing a 62-year-old woman being
brutally dragged across concrete
slamming her body into a steel pole and
leaving her bruised and then stealing
from her two were arrested and cops say
it is connected to at least 62 Grand
Larsen police are still searching for
the group's ring leader today saw a
little bit of Justice come for the
migrant men who were caught beating two
New York City police officers and then
given no bail Homeland Security picking
up some of the suspects wanted at a
Greyhound bus station in Arizona and
earlier today the one and only suspect
who was actually held on bail was in
court a grand jury voted to indict him
on a felony charge as he plad not guilty
and you know the migrant crisis is bad
for Democrats when Al Sharpton is using
this language to describe it you're
getting migrants beating up policemen in
the streets in New York you seeing an
influx of migrants all over the country
that frankly have people outraged we're
looking every day at the invasion of
migrants oh really Greg who would have
guessed I'm surprised MSNBC didn't say
we need more moped
control you know we we talk about this a
lot and it's it's like there has to be a
punishment that sends you back to a
worse place if you hadn't committed the
bad act when you send them back back
it's just a reset button you know you
have to send I really think that we need
prisons in cold places so you take the
violent felons who come here from Sunny
climates and you send them to some place
really cold how soon would that stream
of young criminality dry up when if they
have to risk five years in like Siberia
West but you know the Dems they're the
they're the breaking point party they're
ignorant of incentives and disincentives
so we always end up at this spot which
is chaos and now they care because it
looks bad not because it is bad but
because it looks bad I love that I go
back to that segment from yesterday when
those CNN anchors were so shocked when
John Miller explained how New York's get
out of jail free card uh increases
criminality it was like David Blaine you
know performing street magic to
12-year-olds the CNN anchor like oh my
God how did you do that we had no idea
what a magical you what incentivized to
come to New York you know it's and also
I mean if you got to release him release
him in the neighborhoods where the
people who make those decisions to
release them live let them experience
the reality of their decisions you know
these these uh violent migrants aren't
going to be cutting your Lawns that's
for sure and judge the IL the illegal
immigrant crime spree that is the
highest Rising concern about the
Immigrant crisis after there's
lawlessness of course at the border but
now you have for for example just here
in New York there's one migrant gang
linked to 62 Grand Larsen MH I've always
said Dana that violence has learned
behavior and what the illegals are
learning is that they can commit a crime
they can even assault a men and women in
authority and be let out of jail before
the police finish the paperwork and
that's what's going on here these I hear
the mopeds are many of them are stolen
they're not registered and they're going
after lone females females were walking
alone with a phone in their hands I mean
I don't go anywhere without my phone or
with a purse and they're knocking them
over as you can see right there just
pulling them over she gets hit with
something on the street I don't know if
it's a bicy yeah a pole of some sort but
here's the bottom line when uh Greg is
right when Jesse uh when Al Sharpton
talks about uh an invasion he is talking
about what I was talking about yesterday
and that is the African-American
Community who's getting the short end of
the stick because the illegals are
getting are jumping over them in terms
of all of the benefits that we're giving
them whether it's schools or sports
centers or the ability to get into
programs and Adams this guy Adams I
gotta tell you every day he strikes me
as Dumber he comes out and he says you
know the city council passed the law
that prevents the police from
cooperating with ice so if the police
like if if if I were to Lodge a detainer
with New York City then what would
happen is the police would say we're
letting this guy out and I would have a
detective there like two hours before to
get him they're not allowed to do that
and so Adams throws his hands in the air
he said you know the city council passed
it you fool he can't even answer the
question that was asked of him which is
do you know whether or not you can
change that yourself by executive order
how can you change it you said well we
haven't looked into that we're going to
check it out you haven't looked into it
because you don't care and that's a sad
part and Kathy hokel stop talking you
know she's one those was saying you know
we have to hold these people until we
can figure it out that's not
constitutional okay number one and
number two why don't you increase the
number of crimes in New York that we can
hold people on bail for if we do have
enough to hold them do you think Jesse
for those three that they caught do you
think they ever thought they would get
caught well they weren't caught where
they lived and they haven't been caught
once they crossed so nothing stopped
them now but when you when you have poor
people from underdeveloped countries uh
violent countries leave their families
their mothers and fathers come to
another country sponsored by
cartels there's a certain percentage of
them they're going to gravitate towards
Street crime and perhaps even more
serious gang activity and we've just let
10 million people into the country a
small percentage they're going to be
gang members and they're going to ftiz
and you're going to now grow a small
army of foreign National gang members
within the United States and that only
adds to the Latin American gangs that we
have currently and then they're going to
be fighting with the mafia they're going
to be fighting with uh black drug
trafficking gangs over Turf this is a
recipe for disaster and the fact that
the FBI is just sitting by and watching
this happened why hasn't Chris Ray said
anything about this this is the most
dangerous thing we've done to the
country that I can remember what about
January 6 Jesse besides January 6 har
Ford which is why we need a border Bill
if we're letting thousands and thousands
and thousands of maybe even millions of
people in and we have an opportunity to
reduce that by 20% 30% let alone 50 or
60% doesn't do that well Jess well we
can differ on this let the American
people get put this before Congress for
a vote let's improve the bill where you
think it should be improved because one
thing we know for certain what we're
doing now is broken let me finish my
point I only got 30 seconds here it's
it's not working we get Asylum reform in
this which we've always said we need it
we give the president more authority to
shut down the Border be it this
president or any other president this
this bill gives the president more
Authority than president Trump ever had
and frankly powers that he wished well
if my reading of the bill suggests but
here's the thing I did put it on the
floor for vote Mr Johnson Mr Speaker no
with all due respect you sir if you're
so confident Dead on Arrival let your
caucus and let the Democrats vote on it
let people offer amendments to it then
send it back to the Senate and let's get
our border under control it's broken
unless we want more stories like we're
dealing with in the fact that we already
have the laws on the books and Joe Biden
won't let the border patrol enforce the
laws is reason enough to believe that
even if we pass something Joe Biden's
agenda is to let them in why do you
think the border patrol Union endorsed
this because they didn't have a CH let
them argue in the commercial break up
next President Biden is going to war
with Snickers hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else